ça c'est des lunettes que j'ai de
pharmacie c'est pas des lunettes cher
mais drôlement celle-là ça fait un an et
demi j'ai des bonnes lunettes il y a des
vraies lunettes de pression je les mets
jamais je les aime pas je trouve que
j'ai l'air d'un monsieur oui j'ai cette
manie là comme avec le crayon mais c'est
devenu tout au début ça agaçait plus là
honnêtement les commentaires que je
reçois la 9 sur 10 c'est plutôt
sympathique puis je me suis parlé une
soirée électorale j'avais un crainte
faisait clic clic clic allons faire un
petit tour sur l'île de Montréal je ne
le savais pas que je faisais click les
résultats sortaient pas assez vite que
je vous passe les détails plus de voyons
mais ça j'aurais dû j'aurais dû m'en
apercevoir et sinon j'essaye je me force
pour être pas trop bébé enfin avec